usually this is the part of the show
right come on say man we have an amazing
program - yes I'm gonna be honest with
you I'm not sure what kind of program we
have tonight
no I'm being completely honest with you
yes yes we have a little bit of that
news we have a little bit of an unusual
situation going on with our show and
that is that tonight we are supposed to
be having Kumail Nanjiani on the show
yes okay said his name you just said his
name and he just told you stick around
tonight Conan has Kumail Nanjiani yes
okay he was lying I was just doing my
job sir yeah we don't have Kumail
Nanjiani now we did the plan was to have
Kumail Nanjiani on the show tonight and
we loved him I'm gonna go out of my way
and say we love that guy he's a great
guy very funny man but then what you
guys stop on a dime that was fantastic
then literally half an hour ago half an
hour ago we get a call and he's fine
everything's fine
he's shooting Silicon Valley and there
was some kind of snafu when they're in
their shooting schedule and he's got to
work and he has work to do and he didn't
get released he's in Marina del Rey
shooting a scene and he can't get here
we found that out half an hour ago
while I was having my nap that I have Oh
I was having my pre-show nap
and II was having a bath and heavy cream
I tried and they came in and they said
Kumail can't get here right and I was
thinking about it we've been doing this
over 25 years this show okay thank you
[Applause]
you are just soulless zombie 25 you're
not real people anyway we've been doing
this for 25 years and I cannot think we
were trying to think of when has this
happened before has this ever happened
before and then we realized one time one
time and I think it was in like 1996
about what would you say Jeff Reich
around 1996 something like that maybe 15
20 minutes before the show started we
got a call from our guest and it was
Liza Minnelli
and she said she couldn't make it so
Liza Minnelli canceled and she's known
you know she's a great artist right but
she's known for sometimes flaking out
troublesome yeah troublesome yeah yeah
well Andy said it I didn't so Liza
Minnelli and now in that same category
of troublesome diva Kumail Nanjiani yeah
yeah so let me recap we're a show now
that's changed our format and we're now
a show that has one guest tonight
now for the 25 year run of our show when
we were an hour we would just take the
second guest and move them up and they'd
be the first guest and no one would
really be the wiser but when you're a
show that's based on just interviewing
one guest and that guest doesn't show up
you're really screwed
I mean this could end up being the guy
right here yeah it's gonna hurt you're
selling weed for about a half hour
you'll do the on this side yeah I love a
guy who's still selling weed illegally
in California who says he might own a
dispensary yeah no no no he's still
going around he still has a guitar yeah
no the cops are here to get some so yeah
so what we're gonna do is we're gonna
figure this out as we go along I think
this is exciting so much TV today is
pre-program worked out ahead of time I
don't know why I'm doing Nixon but
that's not this show tonight this show
tonight we don't really know what's
gonna happen we're figuring it out as we
go we will deliver a fine show with the
same high quality as our other fifth
now we did we did now part of the deal
was Kumail was supposed to be here and
wanted to be here so part of the reason
he was here is that he has a movie
opening this weekend called Stuber and
he was gonna come out he was gonna talk
about Stuber and then shove a clip from
his movie right and we were just talking
about it backstage literally swear to
God we found out maybe 2025 minutes ago
that he couldn't be here and so we had
his clip all loaded up and then we
started talking about it and we thought
hey if the guy doesn't show up yeah
we're not gonna show the clip yeah yeah
promoting his movie right exactly that's
not how it works right you got it you
got to show him to get the co you gotta
show up yeah and he said it right you
got to show up to get the cookie
yeah in this case the cookie being
showing your clips showing your clip I
like how we're talking to you all like
you're Morris anyway so no we we're not
going to show the clip from Stuber we're
not going to do that but we are going to
show a clip we're going to show a clip
for the movie that opens against Stuber
this week
it's a I just let you go for a while
there this is a clip for a struggling
little movie yeah that I think needs our
help
yeah this movie opens this weekend
premieres this weekend Damas it's tuber
and we're gonna try and give it a boost
right
and if and and we just think that that's
fair that's karma right I think that's
karma so ladies and gentlemen enjoy this
clip for the Lion King you have to take
your place as king
we need you
[Music]
we have
please please what is your name my name
is Francisco Francisco so cool to meet
you thank you for being here and you're
enjoying the show yes no coupe will you
here for Kumail or it didn't really
matter you just you came for Conan right
no I liked Bautista better in the movie
he seems like you might be more
interesting Carrie do we couldn't get
Bautista yeah he says in the movie with
Kumail yeah okay okay that's all right
you it was a huge mistake to bring you
up here
stay with me here right now you can let
go of us no no no I'm afraid of what he
might do this is part of my way of
restraining him anyway we have here come
on man we have a great show I got my pal
here we have a great show we're gonna
make this up as we go so stick around
we'll be right back